help us change the culture by buying our
latest single from tim cast records only
ever wanted by clicking the link in the
description below
let's jump into this first story finally
here we go from the post-millennial fbi
agent accused of suppressing hunter
biden laptop investigation resigns
escorted out of building now this story
is really interesting because there's
conflicting reports as to whether or not
he just resigned or he was forced to
resign
and this the story from the washington
times is that this guy tim tubal retired
over the weekend but was previously on
leave for about a month
according to the washington times to
bought retired of the weekend on friday
eyewitness accounts state he was seen
exiting the washington bureau's elevator
while being escorted by two or three
headquarters looking types tabal was
named by senate judiciary ranking member
chuck grassley in july in a july letter
to fbi director ray and attorney general
mayor garland at cited whistleblowers
who alleged political bias from
high-ranking officials according to
grassley the whistleblower said the fbi
and justice department employees must
follow strict guidelines to open an
investigation and tabalt did not follow
them he said as you are aware assistant
special agent in charge tim tubal i'm
probably pronouncing it right is not all
is not the only politically biased fbi
agent at the white at the washington
field office adding the fbi answers to
congress and the american people
tabal was one of 13 special agents in
charge of the at the washington field
office and had been under fire from
republicans in congress after it was
revealed that he made anti-trump post on
social media in the lead-up to the 2020
election while he was supposed to be
helping to direct the investigation of
hunter biden
well as we know from these
whistleblowers the fbi blocked that now
donald trump came out and said this is
the guy that was leading the raid on
mar-a-lago
other media outlets have come out said
that's not true but this guy's the
washington field office and it was the
washington field office that was in
charge of this so
all of the news coming out is
conflicting fox news said it's it's
unceremonious that he was escorted out
that's normal and then it was just a
resignation while the washington times
saying he says he's being forced out
who do you believe now this is the
challenge so peter what's going on is
the fbi a bunch of uh a bunch of good
guys just trying to help help us all
live better lives are they're going
after the criminals or are they biden's
personal gestapo yeah let's put this um
in historical context if you go back
to the days of j edgar hoover the fbi
has a has a very
tawdry history
uh abusing my agency
for political ends martin luther king i
think was the poster child
of the wrath of of god um aka jay edgar
but others
many others felt uh the investigatory
weaponization of that agency so
that supposedly went away but but i
would argue and and tim let's put this
this uh hunter laptop biden
incident um in in its broader historical
perspective and we start
when i was on the campaign
in
2016 with donald trump in
trump tower in manhattan
prior to the 2016 election
the so-called russia hoax
began the russia oaks is a discredited
russia hoax
um which was supposed to somehow tie
trump as some kind of puppet of putin
right it's just it's just it was a
democrat
operative
funded by hillary clinton that got it
started but it was the fbi agents like
peter strzok
uh
lisa page comey himself others
and that was where the first
preemptive coup
was attempted
on donald trump okay
what they wanted to do prior to the
election was taint him with the russia
hoax and hillary would win that didn't
work but that russia hoax
continued for for several years led by
former fbi director
mueller and
they took they took a lot of prisoners
to him a lot of casualties i mean mike
flynn i love that guy i was with him in
the trump tower
during the transition we had great plans
he was going to be the national security
adviser we were going to crack down on
china would have made a real difference
they got him in an entrapments game they
got george papadopoulos
they got paul manafort they they did an
over the top rate of roger stone with
frogmen and
guns blazing leaks to cnn there's a
pattern here that's my point here tim
there's a pattern here preemptive coup
prior to 2016
a coup they attempted throughout the
years that trump was in
and fast forward to hunter biden laptop
they succeeded in that coup if you
believe two things one mark zuckerberg
says the fbi told him to suppress any
information about the hunter biden
laptop prior to the election and the fbi
had that thing for over a year they knew
the information was accurate that that
guy was was was into pornography crack
and most importantly influence peddling
but but it's not just that it's that
there's connections between him and his
dad and their business dealings which is
i think more than just being a bad
person according to mark the fbi game a
general
warning like hey watch out for
misinformation and then mark took it
upon himself to censor the accept biden
thing except whistleblowers came out and
said
that they knew the hunter hunter bite
and laptop thing was happening and they
should not investigate it because they
didn't want to interfere in the election
at the same time went to mark zuckerberg
and said hey we want to actually put our
thumb on the scale so watch out for the
information we deem to be misinformation
you can't play it both ways you can and
and interestingly enough last week i had
to i had to step in as a guest host for
brother bannon on his show and when that
story broke that day i interviewed
miranda devine why is that important she
wrote the book laptop from hell
the new york post was sort of broke the
story and twitter
took them off in facebook and what she
said was zuckerberg flat out lied
because
he and face work were much more
aggressive than twitter but here's what
we had actually someone message us in
the super chats last night yeah saying
zuckerberg lied they had they had been
permanently banned from facebook over
sharing the 100 laptop story during the
election yeah he he he made twitter
sound like they were the like the tough
guys and they saw no bs calling bs on
mark but but the main thread here
is
the fbi
i i see them as as an insurrectionist
okay think about this and if you look at
webster's dictionary and insurrectionist
is is armed people who are trying to
overthrow the quote constituted
authority okay trump was president for
four years armed fbi agents in the
executive suites and down
tried to overthrow trump and they
succeeded well now they succeeded the
polls here tim you know what the polls
say about hunter biden laptop right
right right from raspberries and i think
it found what seven percent of people
would have voted for trump had they
known about this yes so trump should be
in the white house but what do you what
do you think about the fbi going after
hillary clinton's emails because the
argument that the left makes is that
well if comey hadn't done the
investigation over her emails she would
have gotten the same bump as she would
have won well uh
in the dual system of justice i'm the
guy in leg irons
trump's the guy who has a uh a raid on
mar-a-lago despite cooperating with the
national archives of incredible bangs
and eric holder who was the attorney
general under obama who killed people
with his his mis operation down in
mexico with with gun running he he was
charged they were wrecked they
recommended the same charge for him as
me he went free hillary's free peter
strucks on cnn making six or seven
figures and that was the sob at the fbi
in the top executive suites
who was directly responsible for
manipulating
information to perpetuate the russia
hoax and so so to finish the thought
it's like now we have another preemptive
coup we had one in 2016 that failed we
had an actual coup by the fbi that
succeeded because they suppressed the
hunter buying information which would
have swung the election to trump and now
we have another attempted preemptive
coup at mar-a-lago trying to stick him
with a criminal charge that would
prevent him from running so the question
here is to this news point is this one
guy how many bad apples are in that
bunch and i go back 13. i
a thousand two i mean how many i go back
to why
i'm here in a little way i think taking
back trump's america books mission is to
get control of the house of
representatives in november so that we
can start issuing the subpoenas to the
fbi the department of justice the
national archives and find out just what
exactly is going on who's calling these
shots who who decided to go down to
mar-a-lago when the guy's cooperating
with him and and go down there with
armed agents what a deal boxes what did
cash patel say
what did cash patel say he thinks
that the boxes they took are related to
some of the cover-ups inside the fbi
related the russians so this is the
affidavit
said that they were covered 15 boxes
uh i think they they they they seized 11
doc
packets of documents or something like
that great am i wrong correct me if i'm
wrong hannah clare
it said that donald trump was instructed
that he had boxes that may contain
classified information by the national
archives so he then sent those boxes oh
yeah here you go take them the national
archives took them went through them and
found newspaper clippings
personal memos from the president and
some classified information spattered
among these boxes
then sent a message to the fbi saying
hey look what trump had the fbi said
sounds like he's got more probably okay
got a warrant on those grounds and the
warrant said from the first day to the
last day of his presidency and then they
went in searched to the house took more
documents so cash thinks the documents
they took were related to russiagate
yeah and that i mean this is a crazy
this is a crazy movie-esque story if
this is really how it played out that
donald trump leaves the white house
declassifying as he goes the crossfire
hurricane documents showing the fbi was
engaged in malfeasance to try and
subvert this country or something like
that
and then while for whatever reason
trump's holding onto these documents not
publishing them
they realize he's got them and they need
an excuse to go in and take them which
is why they needed a broad search
warrant that said from day one to the
last day which is insane the fourth
amendment my understanding prescribes
you need a narrow set for your search
warrant you need to be looking for
something specifically that is approved
of not to simply go to a judge and be
like we think he's got classified
documents good enough for me you can
take anything he has from any point in
his presidency that's insane the um
that that theory may well be true but
what i did was i went and looked at the
statutes authorizing the the search
and
interestingly enough there's a little
clause right there in the statute says
that if you
hav if you were found to contain
confidential documents
you can't run for office
right think about that it's right there
in the statute so it's like this could
be russiagate and i i believe that but
it also could be as simple as they
picked those statutes as a way of
stopping trump from waiting
maybe but
i don't think these people are as
powerful as a lot of people think they
are i think obviously we have this unit
of fbi agents and probably many many
more that are really bad
but this won't stop trump that's that's
that's uh
it just it doesn't make sense trump is
the president he has broad
declassification powers if not
unilaterally classification powers they
try and compare him to hillary clinton
but hillary clinton was not the
president she doesn't determine what is
classified trump does as the president
so kash patel said this i think back in
january anything trump has is
declassified because he was the
president
look it's two things can be true here
well one is that they can have the
powers that they think they have these
are very powerful people okay they put
people in prison i mean look think about
my situation here tim take a guess okay
how much on lawyers have i already
shelled out for what is a misdemeanor
okay think about that thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there is a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm we'll see
you all there